منتخب المغرب يبدع ويحقق فوزا تاريخيا على
بلجيكا لتاييده الاحتجاجات مغني راب
ايراني يواجه عقوبه الاعدام سافرت للقاء
حبي الاون لاين فقلت وسرقت اعضائها هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
البدايه من مونديال قطر 20 22 حيث حقق
منتخب المغرب فوزا مثيرا امام نظيره
البلجيكي بهدفين نظفين خلال المباراه التي
جمعت بينهما لحساب الجوله الثانيه من
المجموعه السادسه في نهائيات كاس العالم
20 22 وجاء الهدف الاول في المباراه في
الدقيقه الثانيه والسبعين من اقدام عبد
الحميد صبري قبل ان يضيف زكريا ابو خلال
الهدف الثاني في الدقيقه الثانيه والتسعين
وبهذا الانتصار باتى اصوله الاطلس يتصدرون
المجموعه السادسه باربع نقاط فيما تجند
رصيد شياطين الحمر في ثلاث نقاط
الى كوريا الشماليه حيث اثارها ظهور
الزعيم كيم يونغ اون رفقه ابنته خلال
فعاليه عسكريه رسميه للمره الثانيه خلال
شهر التساؤلات عما اذا كانت ستحكم البلاد
من بعده وفقا لتكنات صحف عالميه عده وكانت
وسائل الاعلام الكوريه الشماليه وصفت
ابنتك كم يونج اون في ظهورها الاول
بالابنه المحببه للزعيم غير انها رفعت
مكانتها الى الابن الغاليه المحترمه هذه
المره وتوقع خبراء ان ابنتاكين ستشارك في
فعاليات مستقبليه معلنه ضمن مساء لتعديل
صوره الزعيم المعروف بحماسه للتسلح وارسال
رساله الى المجتمع الدولي مفادها ان اطلاق
الصاروخ العابر للقارات هو حدث من الحياه
اليوميه العاديه
واستمرار على سيناريو قمع النظام الايراني
للمحتاجين والمعارضين في البلاد وجه
القضاء تهمه الفساد في الارض والحراب ضد
مغني الراب الشهير توماس صالحي والتي تصل
عقوبتها الى حد الاعدام وذلك بعد اسابيع
فقط من اعتقاله على اثر تاييده الاحتجاجات
المتساعده في جميع انحاء البلاد من جانبها
اكدت اسره صالحي لوسائل الاعلام ان حياه
ابنها في خطر ممدده بظروف محاكمته التي
تمت دون محامي وبعيدا عن الاعلام ويعد
صالح احد الشخصيات البارزه التي تم
توقيفها ضمن حمله القمع واسعه النطاق التي
اعتقل في خلالها عشرات الصحفيين والمحامين
والمثقفين اضافه الى شخصيات من المجتمع
المدني الايراني
وفي جريمه صنعاء تردد صداها في مختلف
انحاء العالم فقدت مكسيكيه حياتها وتم
تقطيع جسدها وسرقه اعضائها بعد ان سقطت
ضحيه للحب اون لاين السيده المكسيكيه
البالغه من العمر واحدا 51 عاما كانت وقعت
في غرام طالب في كليه الطب في بيرو وبعد
اشهر من علاقه حب عبر الانترنت قررت السفر
الى بلده للقائه الا انها اختفت وتوقفت عن
التواصل مع عائلتها وبعد فتره وجيزه عثرت
سلطاته في بيرو على اعضاء بشريه وصلت الى
الشاطئ بعدما كانت مرميه في البحر تم
التاكد من انها تخص السيد المكسيكيه والقت
السلطات القبض على المتهم الذي سافرت ضحيه
للقائه ووجهت اليه تهمتي القتل وتهريب
الاعضاء البشريه
في خبرنا الاخير اكتشف علماء اثار مصريون
مقابر قديمه ترجعوا لعصور مختلفه وتحتوي
على مومياوات ذات السنه ذهبيه وجرى
الاكتشاف في احدى جبانات الاثريه بمحافظه
المنوفيه وذلك من طرف البعثه الاثريه
المصريه فيما يعتقد الخبراء ان السنه
المومياوات الحقيقيه قد ازيلت اثناء
التحنيط واستبدلت بالرقائق الذهبيه حتى
يتمكن المتوفى من التحدث الى الاله
اوزوريس في الحياه الاخره بحسب الاساطير
القديمه